you
look at this audience so it looks like
contemporaries to a large extent have a
singular doctor brilliant is speechless
huh I kind of reminds me of Steve Jobs
and he's a hippie who hasn't dropped a
bit of that but carried far beyond mere
hippie them to planetary consequence and
did it via a route that not that many
take I think and it's gonna suggest you
maybe two bits of reading to sort of
just establish what we're talking about
what happened with your guru in India
and what happened when you were on the
ground dealing with smallpox the last
smallpox in the world in India well
first of all it's really wonderful to be
here and everything that you touch turns
into something amazing all through the
years and secondly can everybody hear
well Lars I was going to say Stewart
said that the path that I took as
circuitous as it was was unusual going
from being a left-wing pinko to being a
hippie living in a monastery to working
for the UN but that was the normal
career path in the 60s
everybody so I I don't know where
anything is in this book
dr. boiling would have in that book tour
for on and off for three months but
nobody asked me to read something
specific that I haven't dog-eared so
what you want me to read which 100
something with the guru with Maharaja
something with can I tell you the story
I'll tell the story because the guy who
wrote this isn't here so do you know the
first time that I met you so I was an
intern at Presbyterian Hospital in San
Francisco and George and I who was then
he Lane Feldman but why then she was
Elaine brilliant we were living on Turk
Street and one day I was walking from
Presbyterian Hospital to my house on
Turk Street and for some reason I walked
by this place where there are a bunch of
hippies in an enclosure and there was a
sign that said the die-in project what
was it called what was the name of your
project well there was the hunger show a
hunger show the light for after that's
right forever all starving together it's
starving these guys are starving yeah
and you were all there and I was on the
outside looking in and later on I got to
be on the inside looking out but that's
when I first so when I first had a
glimpse of you guys because you were a
little bit older than me I hate to admit
and we were classic youthful folly we
thought we were saving the
overpopulation bomb by showing with
people who are going to be looking like
when they got hungry which and then we
had people from
and the hog farm buses were there and
people would drop out and that was them
dying and they would escape because they
got hungry so at the end of my
internship as my internship was ending a
group of Native Americans took over
Alcatraz how many of you are old enough
to remember that that was a pretty cool
moment wasn't that and and the Native
Americans who took over Alcatraz did so
because under the Treaty of Laramie any
piece of property stolen or taken from
Indians which was declared surplus
reverted back to those same Native
Americans and Alcatraz was declared
surplus property and it should have
reverted back but we didn't do it and so
a group of Native Americans took over
Alcatraz
and were there for about 18 months
towards the end of that time a woman
named Lu Trudel who was married to a
good friend of ours John Trudell decided
that the baby that she was carrying she
wanted to deliver an indian liberated
land and there was no water there was no
medicine there were no doctors and herb
Kane began writing in his column is the
no damn doctor here willing to go out
and help deliver that baby is there no
damn doctor is the no doctor is isn't
there a doctor anywhere who's willing to
go out living I thought that was like an
ad that said Larry comment to Alcatraz
so I did and I lived on Alcatraz for
probably about three weeks your hold at
this point about 9:20 knowing the way
that I could have been alive in that
period of time I would want to say 25 I
know a little older than that but not
much the state bed in 1969 so I'd have
been 25 okay
so I lived on the island and of course
the truth is that women deliver their
babies and doctors just stand by and
take credit yeah take credit that's
exactly what it is
but when that baby was born they gave
that that child named wovoka and that's
a magic named wovoka was the pious Sioux
Indian medicine man who started the
Ghost Dance religion and when Avoca was
born on india and liberated land that
night became an electric night and a lot
of a lot of Native Americans cut
themselves there was a lot of bleeding a
lot of people took LSD
I remember one Green Beret who took LSD
that night and kept on cutting himself
and I kept on sewing him up and we
eventually had to evacuate him and I was
on a Coast Guard Cutter and it was kind
of bumpy coming to Pier whatever at 47
49 whatever it was and when I got off
the the ambulance came and took him to
San Francisco General and they pushed me
in front of a bunch of television
cameras and it seemed like every TV
camera and the world was there because I
was the only white guy who had come off
the island and they asked me what do the
Indians want and I'm from Detroit
Michigan I had never met an Indian
before but I must have said something
and over the next couple of days George
and I got phone calls and I got an offer
to play a young doctor in a movie and
that movie was called the medicine ball
caravan and it was also called we have
come for your daughters and the first
day of that caravan of course we did it
I mean that we was the sixties of course
we dropped out of residency and
everything else and ran away with the
circus and the first day of that Caravan
which was pure 37 or something like that
there were 25 buses and it was supposed
to have been the Grateful Dead and the
Jefferson Airplane and wound up being
Jethro Tull and Pink Floyd and that
first day my first job as the one of the
Rock Doc's on that on that trip was to
vaccinate the entire cast against
smallpox why well because we were
thinking who we were going to do a trip
to England and we ultimately did a Pink
Floyd concert and Canterbury and to come
back into the u.s. yet have one of those
little yellow cards I didn't know what
smallpox was I certainly didn't think of
this as some would go with a harbinger
of what I was going to do later on but
one of the first people that I
vaccinated was a guy named wavy gravy
and Stewart and to this day he hasn't
gotten smallpox it's amazing it worked
it worked all of you who are against
vaccination that's the truth his autism
is a little over the top that's not true
late whoever's watching this screaming
that's not sure that was bogus it that
was a fraudulent study honest so here's
the other thing this guy when I met him
he smiled which wouldn't be unusual for
anybody else except he had
rainbow-colored teeth there
and he he was wearing a duckbill hat
with the real Ducks real bill and he had
a jumpsuit that his amazingly gorgeous
wonderful beloved wife then known as
Bonnie Jean Beecher had sold for him
made of rainbows and I looked at this
guy and I said to myself hmm he's not
like anybody I've ever met people are
and I didn't know who he was but
whatever he was I wanted a little bit of
that hmm
so we jumped on the bus George and I and
we stayed together the four of us for 40
years right pretty close to that and
George and I have made 47 years and wavy
and JA have been married 50 years and
they say that hippy relationships don't
last but we we finished the movie in
Canterbury and then we figured out that
we like doing it so we got a couple new
buses and we drove from Canterbury
England to Kathmandu now there's a lot
of reasons we went to government we were
actually altruistic Lee trying to go to
bola Island where there had been a
cyclone and almost a million people had
been killed but there was a war between
East Pakistan and West Pakistan
we couldn't get visas to go there we
turned left and went to come on do and
then we trekked the four of us with the
photographer Ruffin Cooper into two
porters Dow a Tundra pants on a Monday
and we trekked for 30 days into the
mountains and when we were there the
people we met who had nothing were so
kind and generous to us that we made a
pledge to ourselves that if ever our
life circumstances changed and we had
money we wanted to give something back
to the people we met in Nepal and then
we all went off in different places Gary
just stayed and meditated took a bunch
of Goenka courses wavy and JA and I
went back to the US stayed on the buses
George and I corresponded by phone I
wanted her to come back I loved her she
wasn't so sure she had met this other
man that she was living with named neem
karoli baba that's funny actually
we we were together in a psychedelic
painted bus visiting my mother in
Cleveland Ohio when a telegram came from
Gary just saying I am living with neem
karoli baba and Ram Dass and my mother
came and said your wife has left you but
she came back and we went back and we
met him crowing baba I did so that's the
answer to your question how did we get
there the real question is what happened
and so I I was a scientist I think I
still am a scientist I'm proud to be
I'll know on Earth Day because I'll be
marching in the sciences
that'll be think I'm a scientist but
when I first went into the ashram which
is called kenchi and I saw all these
graven images I don't think we have a
picture kenchi there well that's us we
got the indian sub-continent we're
getting there okay but then we that's it
that that's a picture over there of
George and I with our hippie bus in the
Khyber Pass okay and I can I just
digress I I was invited to spend a day
at the Pentagon I got an award and I was
invited to to to speak to the Joint
Chiefs of Staff and give a talk in the
Pentagon auditorium and then get on
Armed Forces TV and speak to three and a
half million soldiers sailors and
Marines I apologized for everything we
did wrong in the 60s complaining
warriors and war and I was asked to
speak about asymmetrical threats to
America and national security and I
thought that before I would start
talking about something like that it was
really important that all the brass and
the auditorium in the me so much brass I
could hardly see the light was bouncing
off of their chests I just thought it
was important to start off being very
honest so when I was doing my slide show
that's the first slide that I showed now
you may not know that I have a doobie in
my hands there and that's that's Khyber
Pass and I said before we get started I
want to thank you for inviting me back
to the Pentagon this is my second visit
of course the first time I was here was
with 500000 screaming anti-war radicals
and you wouldn't let me in and I want
you to know that that's me and
Afghanistan smoking some dope in the
Khyber Pass and that's our psychedelic
bus now there's only two possibilities I
said to these generals scared shitless I
said there's only two possibilities
either you know about that and you still
invited me here in which case good on
you or you don't know about that in
which case we're in a whole world of
hurt
and I counted one two my heart was going
and then they all stood up and applauded
and I said okay this is cool this is me
but there was that moment so how I got
to the Pentagon was because my guru
after I overcame my my fear of graven
images and I almost left because I
thought that it was the wrong place for
me that he showed me something that I
had never experienced before and that's
a picture of him holding my hand and
when he went into a state of
consciousness that I I can't even begin
to describe and I looked at him and I
realized that he loved everybody in the
world didn't matter what color they were
what race they were whether they were
from the seven Muslim countries that are
being barred or from the two hundred
other countries didn't matter if they
were man
women or Muslims or Hindus he loved
everybody in the world and I could feel
it because holding his hand it was like
holding on to some kind I know this
isn't scientific holding on to some kind
of an electrical cable and I had this
fleeting thought that it's cool that he
loves everybody in the world but he's
supposed to love everybody in the world
that's his job description he's a guru
and if you're a rabbi or a priest or a
minister you're supposed to live
everybody in the world but then this
thing happened to me which is that I
loved everybody in the world and I
didn't know this machine did that I mean
none of us came out of the womb with an
operating guide there's no website that
you go to put your name in and tells you
what well your buttons are I don't know
how he touched that button it but he did
it certainly stayed with me all my life
not that I'm always loving everybody a
lot of times I hate certain people but I
do go back to that state of
consciousness every once in a while and
it wouldn't have happened without him in
that moment and gage and I stayed in the
ashram for another year a little less
than a year and one day he called me and
he yelled out dr. America because that
was the name he gave me I didn't get a
cool name like Ram Dass or Krishna Das
or any of the gas brothers I was called
dr. America which really was a bummer I
mean honestly it was a bit of a bummer
how do you explain that you got a
spiritual guru spiritual name so he said
dr. America how much money do you have
which was another bummer because I
thought he was gonna hit me out and I
said I had $500 and he said Jude bola
you're lying
how much do you have in the United
States and I thought and I said I've got
another five hundred dollars in the
United States and in Hindi he began to
chant five hundred dollars here
five hundred dollars there five hundred
dollars here five hundred dollars there
you are no dr. which my mother used to
say to me you only got five hundred
dollars you're no [ __ ] doctor I mean
really you can't do better than that
and then he switched from Hindi you are
no doctor to English and he started
saying you are no doctor you are no
doctor and he was really getting into it
you are no doctor you are UN Oh doctor
United Nations Organization doctor
you're going to become a UN doctor
doctor America is going to become a
United Nations doctor and you're going
to go to villages and you're gonna give
vaccinations and I think I said
something really profound I said what
and we had a wonderful translator Ravi
Khanna who was there and I said what is
he saying is he saying he wants me to
give him an injection I didn't get it
I honestly didn't get it and then he
said no you're going to work for the
United Nations smallpox eradication
campaign because God is going to lift
this one form of suffering from the
shoulders of humanity and you're going
to be part of it and now you know Buddha
said that you will always have old-age
suffering disease these are perennials
but Maharaja was saying that's true you
will always have suffering but I'm gonna
take this one form of suffering away
is gonna give us a break why didn't how
did he know about a smallpox
Oh everybody why should I would be
levitating what do you mean anyway how
would I know I mean I've been asking
that question ever since you didn't get
it from you know we're not focused on I
wasn't even a then I never seen the case
of smallpox I didn't know anything about
smallpox I mean really how didn't even
know that there was a disease called
smallpox that it could be eradicated I
mean I barely remembered that I was a
doctor I was a hippie in an ashram in
the Himalayas we we weren't thinking
like that you know we were thinking like
the old part of our life was gone and we
were just there I have no idea okay so
what do you tell you to do if anything
oh he told me to go with Gurjit down
from the Himalayan ashram that we were
in to New Delhi which I just read today
is the most polluted place in the world
it wasn't then and to go and find the
World Health Organization office and to
go and get my job so we did it was about
10 or 15 hours it was a bus and a taxi
and a train and a rickshaw and we went
down there and we both walked into the
front office and there was a wonderful
woman named Edna Boyer an Anglo Indian
and she was right at the front desk and
she said who are you and I said my name
is Larry brilliant I live in an ashram
my guru said that smallpox is gonna be
eradicated this is God's gift to
humanity and I'm supposed to work for
you and they kicked me out I mean I was
still wearing my ashram clothes and we
went back to the ashram in my heart she
said did you get a job and I said no he
said go back and he I said when he said
right now so we went back on the bus and
the train and the rickshaw and went back
to whi only we walked in and they say
you here again I said yes living a
shaman the Himalayas my group and they
kicked me out again and after about 10
times
we began to get smart Girja had someone
that she knew the Sony's or the barman's
and we borrowed a jacket and I got rid
of my skirt and I began to put a tie on
and got my hair cut because I'm hair
down in the middle of my back and I've
been beard and I walked in and they
kicked me out three four or five times
more and my heart she kept on saying
you'll get your job you'll get your job
you'll get it and he kept pushing me and
we kept going back and we were pretty
close to I was pretty close to losing
faith I don't think you're at you ever
lost faith but I was pretty close to
this journey and one day I walked in
there and there was an American there
and I had never seen an American in the
w-h-o office before he looked like a big
football coach he was about six foot
three and news from Ohio and and this
big wonderful open Midwestern face and
he said hi who are you and I said hi my
name is Larry brilliant I'm a doctor I
live I'm a shaman the Himalayas my guru
said the smallpox was eradicated I'm
supposed to come work for WH o and help
eradicate smallpox who are you he said
my name is da Henderson I'm the head of
the small talk program I've come here
from Geneva we don't have a small parts
program yet in India we want one we
think the last battle against smallpox
will be fought here but we don't have a
program because mrs. Gandhi hasn't
authorized us to have a program here and
he thought about it for a while and we
went upstairs to see Nicole Gracia was
the head of the program and they said
why don't you have dr. Henderson
interview you and he can write a note to
the record in case circumstances change
and ten years later after we had
eradicated smallpox and I had started
off working in villages and then
districts and then states and then every
once in a while I was the head of the
program while all the people who really
knew what they were doing were out of
town or sick after we had finished and
eradicated smallpox and made two billion
house calls with a hundred and fifty
thousand people from 170 countries
Muslims and Hindus and
Jews Christians and James and the highs
all working together Russians and
Americans who had 40,000 nuclear weapons
pointed at each other
bearing 40,000 hatchets to work together
and we had eradicated smallpox and I'd
gone back to Michigan I became a
professor at University Michigan here
she was getting her PhD da called and
said I want to go back to India and
collect all those records and put them
in archives and put him on microfilm and
I did and as I was doing that I violated
the most sacred unwritten rule of all
which I looked at my own personnel file
and I found that memo that da Henderson
had done when he interviewed me on that
day when he said we don't a program but
we may have one and he had written I
have today interviewed a young man named
Larry brilliant he says he's a doctor he
does not look like one he says his guru
told him to come work for the United
Nations we don't have a place for him we
certainly don't have a place for him he
appears to have gone natives and DEA had
read every word of every book I've ever
written about smallpox and proof read
every everything I ever ever did and he
got about halfway through this book
before he died I hope it wasn't the
writing and Gary Jenai about two months
ago went to his memorial he was almost
90 years old and a wonderful man and he
was our chief and we got to work with
some of the finest people in the world
of the of the ten people who we work
with the closest each of them got the
highest award that their country can
give them hmm though [ __ ] and da got
the Presidential Medal of Honor dinner
yeah she got the Czechs the pocky and
equivalent of that Nicole got the French
Legion of Honor
yes our Rita
and rice and MIT Sharma who was adopted
me like my my father and I called him
papa and he called me Sonny he got padma
bhushan and those are the people who
taught me epidemiology and we eradicated
smallpox and I don't know how that
happened I mean I know I know exactly
what we did I know how we visited every
house in India every month and found
every case and put a circle of immunity
around it with vaccine
did I mention for those of you who are
anti vaccine maybe I didn't mention the
fact that we would still have smallpox
if we didn't have a vaccine I'd also
like to mention we had that vaccine for
a hundred and seventy years before we
eradicated smallpox so it's not just the
vaccine it's having 150 thousand people
from 170 countries all working together
did I mention there were not as
incompetent shits as somebody in the
White House would make us think did I
mention that our species can really do
noble things we're willing to all work
together and we're stronger together and
we don't have to pretend that it's only
one plane of our species that is more
important than the others say a little
about the ground work one of the things
that got from your Bikila surprised me
as you put a picture of your guru in the
windshield of your vehicle and that
actually was cred in some places who
went to if not with the UN how does that
work so mahadji had a reputation for
being a bit of a prophet in parts of
india he and in and i can't separate
words from fact you know when he died
the newspaper said he was 300 years old
and i just don't think that was true but
you know no but but one of the one of
the rumors about mahadji is that when
mrs. Gandhi was a young minister and her
father who was narrow was the Prime
Minister the Chinese invaded India in
1962
well that's true that's just
and they came in through two parts of
India but Ranaut on one side and the
other side near Darjeeling and the
Himalayas and the story is that they
were in a cabinet meeting trying to
decide how they would wage war with the
Chinese and the phone rang and mrs.
Gandhi picked up the phone and it was
mahadji on the phone and she had known
him before as like a household and he
said don't do anything the Chinese will
go home within three days and of course
not everybody in that room believed that
but they waited and the Chinese turned
around and went home and to this day if
you read the history of that invasion
nobody knows really why the Chinese
turned around I'm not saying that my she
made the Chinese turn around I don't
know but that's just that was one of the
rumors so when we were working in the
smallpox program if they understand
almost nobody believed we could
eradicate smallpox smallpox was not
really a regular disease it was
ubiquitous all over the world everybody
had it I mean it you the scale of it was
so much that in the 20th century how
many of you were alive in the 20th
century come on there was only 18 years
ago so I mean right in the 20th century
500 million people died from smallpox
half a billion people I mean it's not
like that was a long time ago but it was
everywhere and almost everybody in w-h-o
thought that we were crazy smallpox was
the fourth disease considered for
eradication we had failed to eradicate
yellow fever mostly because monkeys do
not stand in line putting their arms out
to get vaccinated and monkeys get yellow
fever we'd failed to eradicate Yas we
had failed to eradicate malaria
so it wasn't unduly skeptical to think
that we wouldn't be able to eradicate
smallpox and in fact in all the time I
worked in w-h-o I never met a single
w-h-o official who believed that we
could eradicate smallpox except the
people working on a small pocket program
and I write in the book
a story of a head of communicable
diseases this is the top guy da work for
him we all worked up for the head of
communicable diseases doctor if not a
[ __ ] a Polish epidemiologist and he
said trying to eradicate smallpox in
India is one of the dumbest things I've
ever heard of it's a fool's mission you
might be able to eradicate it in America
because it's a rich country you might be
able to eradicate in Burma because it's
a totalitarian government but you'll
never eradicate it in India and I'm so
sure that if you ever could eradicate
smallpox I will eat the tire from a land
rover and really one of the happiest
days of my life was when the cold grass
a took a tire of a land over to paalam
Airport in New Delhi and put it in a
crate and wrote a little note dear
doctor it not a [ __ ] and clothes please
find one tyre from one land rover would
you kindly report back to us the texture
the bouquet and if you need any mustard
or ketchup so it wasn't exactly that
everybody agreed that we'd be able to do
that it was hard
so it's an incremental progress that was
keeping people encouraged that one
region over another would get cleansed
and that would take you to them exactly
it was a great it was a great strategy
you you kind of pick off the low-hanging
fruit mm-hmm and you you work in
countries that you think you've got a
better chance at it and by the time we
got there there were only four countries
that still had smallpox when the program
began in 1965 there were 35 countries
and then we did the same thing inside
India you would go to the cut the states
that were better developed which were
the southern states and you'd work there
first and you put a ring around the most
difficult States which were the four
hindi-speaking state's budget Pradesh
Bihar Uttar Pradesh and for the we'll
call Bengali Hindi speaking state it
isn't really but those four states were
the last states in the world with
smallpox and this little girl with that
balloon that's the last case
of killer smallpox to occur in nature
and her name is Rehema banu and she was
in bangladesh and a little island called
bola island the very same island that
wavy and john birch and I set off to go
to that it had that terrible cyclone she
was a little village called koroliov
village and when the scabs fell off her
and she coughed and the last virus has
left her body and landed on the ground
in Bangladesh and they were cooked by
the Sun that was the end of an unbroken
chain of transmission of one of the
worst diseases if not the worst disease
in human history and I was there and I
took that picture and I bought that
balloon smallpox can't be stopped in San
Jose and I carried those balloons around
with me for two years I never dreamed
that I would be actually seeing the last
case of smallpox but that's it that's
that that when I started writing this
book which took me 40 [ __ ] years
most great reliefs have this off your
mind yeah I lost 40 40 tons of weight I
mean when I started writing it I wanted
to chronicle the story of Maharaji and
the story of George and I traipsing all
over the world and wavy and John gears
and I'm playing around for so long I
wanted to chronicle that story I didn't
dream that we would elect somebody as we
elected someone and when towards the end
of writing that book that this
hate-filled
political campaign began my purpose
shifted a little bit I wanted a book
that would be a proof point of a time
when all of us working together could do
something magical and not just something
that you make up but something for which
this historical fact I wrote a
scientific book on smallpox eradication
peer-reviewed that's what I used to make
sure that every date and every number
was right Garrincha kept the diary with
my Raja so did I I wrote three 400
reports for WH o so the science in the
book is right and I wanted that story of
how we had eradicated smallpox to offer
it as not an antidote but contrary
evidence to the idea that we can't do
anything because we can we can really do
great things together okay and that
little girl is proof let's bring it into
the present tonight you're gonna leave
right after this to go to where Aspen or
LA and you talk you know what that is
giving pledge people to raise money for
what so I work a lot on pandemics a
friend of mine Jeff Skoll who was the
first president i bay when first
employee eventually he started a couple
of foundations and one of them is the
skull global threats fund and I ran that
for seven years now I'm chairman of that
and one of uh we work on five threats we
work on pandemics and climate change and
water and nuclear weapons and regional
wars that could become workers cheerful
subjects like that and we become I don't
know we sort of a mixed story about
pandemics you know Ebola and Zika MERS
and SARS Lassa fever swine flu bird flu
there's been more more animal viruses
jumping from animals to humans in the
last thirty years then we have records
of before and that's worrisome but much
more worrisome than that is that but
institutions that normally keep us safe
are sort of a wall in the Ebola outbreak
Obama sent 3,500 American soldiers to
West Africa we spent billions of dollars
because w-h-o failed in its job to
protect us
because it's a
six months to correctly identify what
the disease was that was killing people
in West Africa so WH o is going to have
a new director-general in May and I
think it's going to go through a period
of self-examination and it's offline huh
and I think this presidency as far as
pandemics is offline you know you're not
gonna see Public Health let alone
pandemic preparedness at the top of the
priority list for this White House and
they fired the head of CDC and they're
cutting Sunday for Disease Control
Center for Disease Control or centers
and Trump is cutting the budget for
Public Health and pandemic preparedness
there's a new Secretary General of the
UN who just began the first of January a
really good guy Portuguese guy really
good but he's just getting started so if
you look at those agencies that normally
keep us safe the federal government
w-h-o the UN CDC they're all off line
we've got a great head of the World Bank
was a dr. Jim Kim he'll be working
really hard but by and large we have to
have a safety net to protect us to stop
pandemics to end the threat of pandemics
so I'm going to be trying to put
together a new organization and and this
is being broadcast everywhere so I can't
tell you how much money but Jeff Skoll
gave us a lot of millions of dollars to
start up an organization to work on
pandemics and I'm hoping that other
people will be interested what's it
called hmm what's the our organizations
ending pandemics and what will it do so
it will be a civil society private
sector augment augmentation to
government you can't replace governments
but in this period of time when you've
got brexit
you've got the centrifugal forces
tearing them apart all the post Second
World War international agreements
you've got to have something else that's
on alert and why
trying to build a cadre a cohort of
epidemiologists and other people who are
working to make us safe and Thank You
Ryan this we start going with some
feedback from the audience here and you
can raise your hand and Michael will
sort of identify you and then get a mic
to you and I and while you're doing that
there's a guy here you can always use a
spill right if there's everything if
there's ever a delay in anybody asking a
question you can always just hand this
guy a mic he doesn't he's a microwave he
doesn't he startup time well we're
working up on that I do have one
question which is not in the book but I
know you had a sort of lifelong
friendship with Steve Jobs and there was
a hippie down to his bare feet his
entire life but he went to India and
sort of in the biographies there so he
went to India mobile mobile and then he
came back did anything happen to Steve
and then you well we were in the mumble
mumble so Steve was a student at Greene
college and he heard about neem Karoli
Baba about our guru that guy and he
decided he was gonna come to India to
meet him and he had to get all of his
stuff together and raise the money to go
there by the time he got there Maura she
had died and she got there six months
after her how she died so it took a
little while to get his stuff together
and he wandered in our and the ashram
that we lived in this is the ashram that
Ram Dass lived in and Dan
lived in and Christian awesome and Steve
Jobs and he was nineteen years old and
he was barefoot shaven had and and
wandering around and the first time I
met him was when he showed up at the
w-h-o office in New Delhi because the
rumor was that there was somebody
working there who had five minutes ago
been a hippie living in that same harem
and you could get a free lunch and it
was air-conditioned and he came and he
had lunch and he had a lot of salads and
he was 19 and that's when I first met
him and when we started the sabor
foundation they gave us the first money
to start saving what was save us save a
foundation is what is save a save as an
organization a group of us started after
we eradicated smallpox and it was the
founders were people who worked in this
ball park program or who were friends of
ours
during the smallpox program and like
every other organization started in the
60s we had UN diplomats and
epidemiologists and scientists and
professors and mystics and a clown
and now almost 40 years later savers
programs and projects have given back
sight to four and a half million blind
people in 25 countries or so they're
here who has the mic what's your
question I have the mic here and
actually my question was about saving
because he hadn't mentioned it when I
was given the mic so I'm gonna turn that
into a thank you for the work that
you've done I've been a save a supporter
since the first very first year with the
Grateful Dead announcing it at a show at
the Greek theater so wavy thank you and
Larry thank you for that work and I also
want to ask how what you're doing with
the diabetes programs for the Native
American population so we thank you very
much for that so say there has kind of
moved the diabetes project into a
blindness project with Native Americans
because that's what we we were good at
is working on blindness we had a lot of
other programs at one time or another we
had for iguana mala we we worked on the
accompaniment of Guatemalan refugees the
Jaguar project and we realized that
we've gotten good at one thing in that
spinous so we kept working with all the
people as best as we could but we worked
on trying to get rid of blindness in all
of those communities and that's sort of
how we got up to four and a half million
and there's somebody here who's a friend
of papi and javi and her husband are
part of the Arvin family and I can't
talk about savers four and a half
million without mentioning this
incredible eye hospital in South India
and mother died which did most of these
eye operations created most of these
techniques and has helped us as we've
tried to lower the cost of a inter
ocular lens from two hundred and fifty
dollars down to 85 cents because
because when you talk about appropriate
technology a lot of people fail to
mention the cost and something that is
inappropriate at $250 is very
appropriate at 85 cents you're here
you're at you brilliant repeat the
question the question is to talk about
the well and what we guys did together
I'll tell my side of the story his will
be very different but not that different
we took your money and we ran with it
that's it yeah I think that's probably
more true than I would like to admit but
do you know why I had that money no ah
you see so there's another part of the
story so when we're starting Saiva
we wanted to because we were hippies we
wanted to do the best science we could
you understand how that works we want to
be impeccable and to do that we wanted
to build a program that looked a little
bit like a ham sandwich and it had a
epidemiological survey was one piece of
bread and then an outcome survey was
another piece of bread and the ham was
actually the program doing it so I was
asked to run a survey of blindness in
Nepal which is easier to say than to do
because you have to have a random sample
of all the villages in Nepal but a third
of Nepal is inaccessible in the
mountains and that meant that 1/3 of all
the villages you couldn't really reach
very easily on foot so we had to have a
helicopter and that first concert that
you talked about that the Grateful Dead
did was wavy talk to Grateful Dead into
doing a concert to pay to fly the
helicopter to Kathmandu okay I got to
finish the story hold that thought
oh that is this is pretty good no chance
we we had had our little first BT and
forming Savea and I was instructed to
try and get these boys to play a concert
for us like everybody says we have a
cool thing let's get the Rolling Stones
or what
and unlikely but I did have a few
connections and we went from where we
had the meeting to the airport in
Detroit and I got on the airplane and
who else was on the airplane but the
Grateful Dead and they did that
parachutes and the rest is history
[Applause]
so so we had to great for that and maybe
wavy has done I don't know a hundred and
fifty save a concert and benefits maybe
half that only seventy five strike that
one fifty insert 75 but that's the hell
of a lot of concerts maybe 10 15 the
Grateful Dead did concerts something
like that but we did this survey and we
had a helicopter
we had the helicopter for six months we
went to a hundred and eight villages
with that helicopter and when we
finished the survey on the last day the
last village far away the helicopter
crashed now it crashed in this magical
way that an oak leaf crashes in the fall
when it comes down like this and the
coal grass say who was in the helicopter
at the time looked to Darien Ward who
was the pilot and said what's wrong as
he had real white knuckles and he turned
to her and said nothing
just a simple spare parts order engine
one and we had to figure out how to get
a replacement engine into a remote part
of India and I had this computer that
Steve Jobs had given us with a 300 baud
acoustic haze modem the one that goes
if a cat's making love you know and
somebody from the UN said why don't you
just use that and grab that satellite
that's flying over and Link it in to the
Stanford system notepad or the
University of Michigan confer and I did
that and we managed to have a computer
conferencing call and we had senator
Hatfield's office in Oregon because they
had given McMinnville Oregon swear the
helicopter came from
we had the saver office in Chelsea
Michigan with the UN office in New York
where the US ambassador to India on the
call we had nine different people on a
conference call this is late in nineteen
eighty years this is 1980 or late 1979
and this was the first global event like
that and it got written up and bite and
a lot of people wrote about it but most
importantly when we came back to analyze
the data from the survey Steve Jobs was
visiting us and staying at our house and
I showed him this system that we had
cobbled together in a kind of
gerrymandered stupid fashion and he
looked at it and he said that's the
ugliest thing I've ever seen
whereupon I did the only time in my life
I ever asked him for money I said Steve
we're gonna need more money and he said
why don't you take your own ugly thing
make it into a product take it public
make your own money and fund your own
effing charity and I'll help you and he
did and he helped us to meet investment
bankers and take that public and we were
public when I met Ryan who was then
patty in San Diego not San Diego what's
voya
in Lahori odd right next to San Diego
and I said Ryan I've got this idea I've
got this money I've got a company just a
public why don't we take this technology
that I've got and you guys with the
whole earth community and want to do
something like that should we have lunch
and I said steward should we have lunch
and Stuart said well Ryan wants to go to
Black's beach because we're gonna do
some nerd nude body surfing and so I
don't know if I can do it but let's make
it quick and what did Ryan say yeah so
we had lunch and I pitched Stuart and
and and it was exactly as he said my
great negotiating skill was how about if
I give you the money and a VAX computer
and the software and you make this thing
work and he did and that's how the whole
earth latronnik link got started and
then this genius managed to do stuff
that nobody never done before with
electronic bulletin boards and computer
conferencing and I was smart enough to
stay the hell out of the way and protect
us actually at your home corporation
that would have squished us if they'd
known we were there we did we did hide
that yeah so more questions out here all
right I was gonna ask about the well
let's stand up and let's see you Thanks
hello hi so I was gonna asked about the
well initially but since that's been
answered
what would you say Larry was the role
that psychedelics has played in your
life and your sort of journey and
whether you see a place for it today
your partner on stage has been known to
I think he called it a a dead and kind
of akin to geodesic domes and sort of
left it behind but I'm curious what your
take is so I was young and they were
legal
[Applause]
so on this magical bus trip that was a
Warner Brothers movie every Friday they
would pay the crew and we get paid out
of the paymaster's wagon which was like
an old 1955 woody Chevrolet you know
with the wood sides and the producer
would open up the back tailgate and all
the crew would stand in line and there
were two strong boxes one of them had
cash the other had something else and
you could choose and I don't remember
ever taking any cash
and I think and I think that if I had
taken cash I wouldn't have been open to
meet named curly bhava more understood
anything about the mystical experience I
am NOT an advocate for drugs God knows
we have had friends of ours who died
with heroin needles in their arm falling
down an open elevator shaft people that
we loved we've lost people to drugs for
every year for decades I'm not an
advocate I also can't lie and the
experiences that I had opened up another
way of looking at things that a kind of
square
nerdy Jewish boy from Detroit Michigan
wouldn't have found and I'm really
grateful that there were two strong
boxes in the back of that woody
Chevrolet next question
Peter I want to stand up again so so you
eliminated smallpox infectious diseases
are still real the world is doing a bit
better today than we were when you
started your campaign what's the next
disease oh I think we're really close to
eradicating polio you you may have seen
in airports some celebrity holding their
fingers like that saying we're this
close they're talking about we're this
close to eradicating polio and I'm well
aware that we've been saying we're this
close for eight years but we're really
this close last year there were 18 cases
of polio in Pakistan nine cases in
Afghanistan no cases anyplace else in
the world and that's close it's really
hard and polio is harder even though in
smallpox we didn't have cell phones we
have computers we didn't even have faxes
but polio doesn't have the indication of
the disease on your face in smallpox a
hundred percent of people who got
smallpox had the disease and polio is
like one out of a thousand that means
999 that can carry the virus and you
don't know it and these folks have been
working like crazy and they're heroes
when I say they're heroes I don't use
that word lightly
there have been 85 polio workers
murdered by the Taliban in Pakistan and
so this is not just you know an
intellectual exercise and we did a movie
called the final inch paying homage to
these heroic polio workers and when that
story is written that's going to be the
story of our generation in the
eradication of polio by the way we're
this close to eradicating another
disease that you've never heard of
called any worm yes the Kunkle Isis the
fiery serpent from the Bible one of the
worst diseases in the world were worms
that can be four feet long inhabit your
body and come out trying to seek water
and will come out I'm not gonna show I
do this to you through your eye through
your nose it's a really bad disease and
President Carter has spent the last 20
years of his life
to eradicate guinea worm and usually
when I do the slideshow I show a press
conference that he did when he announced
that he had brain cancer metastasized to
his brain and someone said to him how do
you feel about coming this close to the
end of your life and he looked into the
cam rhesus I only have one request that
the last guinea worm dies before I do
which itself is interesting because it's
a deliberate extinction of a species
that has been going on for 30 years the
60s I think was when the decision was
made to try to eliminate guinea worms
from the universe in order for this
disease to disappear mainly from Africa
there used to be millions of people that
got it and that's what we've done and
about to have done and it's a great
thing to have accomplished what else
what else is on the list malaria you
know if we have if we get a vaccine
against malaria I'd give us a really
good shot because other than not being
able to protect people and develop
immunity against the parasite the rest
of the epidemiology is very favorable
except the climate change is making it
harder to do any of these things the
reason we have Zika is because of
climate change historically the 80s
Egyptian mosquito only lived within a
hundred miles of the equator its climate
change that allowed it to move the
Anopheles mosquito which carries malaria
has increased its sway over an
additional billion people because of
climate change which warms up by
latitude and altitude used to be you
were safe if you were living at six
thousand feet because mosquitoes
carrying these diseases couldn't go that
that's not true anymore
so I think that we can one by one
eliminate these disease
but I really want us to eliminate the
one that I worry about the most and I
think I'll end with this good April
seventh is World Health Day
it is also 100th anniversary of the
great influence of the Spanish Influenza
1917 to 1918 pandemic one of my
grandparents died in that one of
George's grandparents died in it I
wonder how many other people know that
in your you know in your genealogy some
of your relatives died from that because
somewhere between 25 million and a
hundred million people died in that one
year period and if you put that to
today's numbers you're talking about 75
to 300 million if we had a pandemic 1/10
of that 100th of that it would bring
humanity to its knees there wouldn't be
an airplane in the sky for six months
who's gonna get on a cargo boat with 300
people that who's epidemiological status
you don't know when there's no vaccine
and no antiviral I want us to stop the
risk of pandemics we know almost every
well we know every step to take we know
how to do it there will inevitably be
outbreaks they'll be viruses jumping
from animals to humans outbreaks are
inevitable but pandemics are optional we
don't have to have them if we have the
same public will to end them that we had
to eradicate smallpox and that's what
I'm hoping that we can pull off next
thank you movies ain't misbehaving get
it it's it's the wavy gravy movie Saint
misbehaving it is just an afternoon
you're not gonna talk about your own
movie you you talk about my book I'll
talk about your man okay this movie
sucks brilliant
tree flesh delicious it's it's thank you
very it's it's like a period piece it's
like you know why did we do the 60s you
want to know see same misbehavior you
can get it through save up if you're
saver you get off Amazon Amazon yes
and Google Play I'm so sorry how could I
have forgotten Larry thank you I will
end a little bit of a challenge for you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]